[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the 220 breakout session improving the
patient experience with cloud endpoints
my name is Angela Goss and since this is
a healthcare dedicated breakout today
and since we are at Google cloud next in
the midst of 35,000 people in a two and
a half block radius and in healthcare
we're focused on wellness I would be
remiss as a certified yoga instructor
not to take us through a quick moment of
mindfulness so if everyone wants to just
get into a comfortable seat in your
chairs and sit up straight or find some
comfort let's take a quick inhale
through the nose and an open mouth
exhale did that feel good I'm getting
some head nods excellent let's do it one
more time just for fun ready inhale
through the nose and exhale through the
mouth
wonderful thank you for indulging me and
hopefully that was good for you too
okay quick a housekeeping note for
today's session in case this is anyone's
first breakout at the conference this
year we're doing something a little bit
different and we brought our Dory
platform to the conference Dory is a
platform that we use internally here at
Google for questions and answers so if
you want you can open up the next app
click on the session that we're in today
improving the patient experience with
Cloud endpoints click on the Dory link
and then you can type in any question
throughout this session today one of the
unique features about Dory is that you
can actually up vote or downvote
questions if you also happen to have
that question and if you type in the
answer and we don't get to it or I'm
sorry the question we don't get to it by
the end of the session I can personally
assure you that myself or someone from
my team will actually answer that
question by the
end of the week so just wanna make sure
everyone feels let they have the
opportunity and let's uh with that let's
get started so it's fair to say that the
cloud transition has fundamentally
changed the way that we live in our
personal lives did anyone take a lyft or
an uber on the way to the conference
today I see a lot of hands did anyone
use Google Maps to plan their trip to
San Francisco a lot of hands possum did
anyone use entertainment apps like
Netflix or Spotify to enjoy
entertainment on the way here excellent
and what is one thing that all of these
apps have in common they allow instant
access to data no matter what device
you're logging in from and through this
access to instant information in our
personal lives it's also increased our
expectations of how we expect technology
to work in our work lives well the same
is true in health care
today's caregivers and patients alike
our cloud natives and they expect to be
able to use technology to give better
care and increase space time with our
patients or receive better care and have
more face time with our doctors through
the use of technology more wired
consumer oriented and innovative than
ever before
the healthcare industry is and has been
undergoing profound transformation
starting to cater to one-click
experiences healthcare is starting to
look like other industries and a truly
consumer driven industry or marketplace
is taking shape
patients are gravitating toward
providers who are meeting these higher
digital expectations and the good news
is that when providers invest Accenture
actually recently posted that providers
can boost margins by as much as 50% in
meaning patients expectations on the
flip side providers are more and more
reporting feelings of burnout has anyone
here heard about physician burnout yes
we have heard about it I actually went
to an event for the American Heart
Association in Chicago on Saturday night
and the chairperson of the organization
referenced this exact same statistic in
that example the goal of the
organization was to acknowledge the
burnout and in intake in more mindful
practices to reduce stress of care
providers ultimately lowering the
potential for heart disease in our case
here today we're talking about how we
can leverage technology to reduce some
of those experiences of burnout the
thing is as most of you raised your hand
today health IT and health leadership
has heard this they know that patients
want more from their technology and that
providers also want that help to
increase face time but the challenge is
managing and delivering on those
expectations while increasing or
maintaining security and reducing the
cost of care in the third quarter alone
of 2018 4.4 million patient records were
compromised in 117 different data
breaches
that's staggering and increasingly every
year that studies are coming out the top
concern of US hospitals is reducing the
cost of care while meeting financial
targets so most everyone agrees that
things can be done better specifically
in the areas of better integration
better support better training increased
security and of course lowered costs
here at google cloud we would offer that
the key to security and simplicity can
be found in our cloud through it you can
find an increase in access to
information so that providers are not
spending as much time looking for the
data and spending more time giving care
reduce operational costs increase
security and protect the pH I and fight
the cyber attacks that are coming out
this is the same technology that we're
offering that Google uses internally as
our own organization just keeping that
in mind and also offering better value
imagine being able to perform clinical
duties in the morning and then go on
Hospital rounds in the afternoon and log
in from home to access your data from
any device or location that you might be
in this would mean that you might have
the access to give better time and
potentially treat situations as they
arise
transformation for your organization
could look like anytime anywhere fast
access to patient information be it web
mobile or other legacy based application
reduced cost and complexity specifically
in the face of budget cuts and funding
uncertainties better insights to drive
decision-making helping out with the
goal to improve improve population
health through IOT and big data
analytics stronger information security
and improved access to patient hair be
it through retail clinic telehealth home
monitoring or other virtual option
meeting patients where they are and
ultimately giving them a better feeling
of care chrome Enterprise is the best
choice to put the power of the cloud and
your providers hands and ultimately
improve the patient experience for your
healthcare organization the solution is
secured by design with a multi-layered
approach to security it includes
comprehensive AI driven threat
protection automatic updates verified
boot and the ability to wipe lost or
stolen devices within minutes it's easy
to share and manage the management
console comes with two hundred plus
security policies that you can provision
at the user or the device level so that
you can control and curate the end user
experience of choice and through the
seamlessness of the management console
it is you're able to manage hundreds if
not thousands of devices with a very
lean IT staff and we do have some
studies out there I would definitely
encourage you to check out and it's a
smart investment by increasing end-user
productivity and read
using operational costs for your health
care practitioner chrome enterprise is a
great solution because it provides ready
access to healthcare apps and VDI so
whatever application your care provider
needs to deliver on to the end-user
patient Chrome is able to help you do
that
additionally it's a fast and familiar
interface that's as easy as navigating a
browser one of my favorite things about
Chrome OS as an end user is that these
devices boot within six seconds and they
come out of standby in three seconds
which if you can think about the course
of your day and every time that you log
in log out restart your computer that
cuts down on a lot of downtime
and additionally with the automatic
updates you don't have to wait or your
system is going to restart in four
minutes and you get that notification
automatic our updates happen seamlessly
in the background and finally a variety
of devices help meet end users where
they are to perform any function so we
have in our form factor options the
Chromebook which is our notebook
offering we also have tablets and two
and ones we have the chrome box which is
our desktop offering and a chrome base
which is an all-in-one and these are
available through all of the major OEMs
that you're already working with
companies like Acer 8a open HP Dell
Lenovo go ahead and check out what their
chrome solution looks like and for your
patient chrome offers autonomous access
to information so they can access their
data instantly and from wherever they
might be it also increases FaceTime with
a provider while they are at a facility
and it provides a feeling of more
personalized care when the FaceTime is
increased between the
and the patient in its total economic
total economic impact model Forrester
ran a study and found the following
results in a composite organization of
50,000 users using 15,000 Chromebooks
and averaging 10 devices per user over a
three-year period of time these were the
results 1.5 million dollars in hardware
and software cost avoidance 3.5 million
dollars worth of employee productivity
gained 75 percent improvement in IT
productivity and $50,000 saved per
device
when remotely disabled in the event of
loss or theft these are great numbers
and you might be thinking wow Angela
that's awesome but how does it affect my
organization well I would encourage you
to Google Chrome Enterprise TCO and
you'll find our friends at ESG actually
put together a calculator for us so that
you can put in all of your own inputs
including the number of end users that
you have the type of job function that
they are whether it's frontline or
knowledge worker the productivity
software that they use and there are
some other questions to follow as well
so definitely check this out as a
resource after the session today we also
have a robust ecosystem of partners so
chrome was invented ten years ago and
today is the number one leveraged
platform in the education space well on
the journey over the last 10 years and
people finding out about chrome through
this growth they've said you know hey
Google can
Chrome do this for my organization and
over time Google listened and every time
that a customer asked and we weren't
able to deliver we created unique
partnerships with these organizations
and so today we are able to deliver on a
great deal of clinical workflow for your
organization calling out to such
partnerships which are basically
basically mission-critical for us at
this point in time Citrix and VMware the
reason why these partnerships are so
strategic is because largely today the
major EHR companies electronic health
record which is the number one thing
where care is given from where
information is input to and accessed
from are typically still legacy based we
probably will see a migration to the
cloud at some point for those
organizations in the future but for
today through our partnerships with
these VDI organizations we're able to
deliver EHR through VDI on the chrome
platform so Chrome Enterprise improves
the patient experience in the following
ways it's helping the healthcare
practitioner
through a variety of form factors
instantly access information reducing
some of that burnout and helping their
patients a little bit better from the
patient experience patients have more
access to information and more face time
with their doctors which gives them a
better sense of care and finally
customer service by helping through
different use cases at both on the front
line and back of house support patients
feel that they're cared for and they're
able to get their questions answered
quickly
so now that we talked about how the
solution works let's talk about what
some of the actual use cases for chrome
and healthcare looks like and what some
of our customers are doing today
starting with the mobile health care
worker in this use case we're typically
deploying Chrome in a one to one
capacity on a tablet a Chromebook or a
two-in-one convertible device and this
really looks like the clinical plus
knowledge worker hybrid solution for
mobile VDI if you will and again all of
the major OEMs you can find a one of
those form factors from them one thing
that we used to hear is you know that's
great and I'm really liking the solution
but I need a for the provider to be able
to work even when they're not on a Wi-Fi
network and the good news is that we do
have el-tee options than the hardware
portfolio today so that you can have
that connectivity at any time shared
workstations so this looks like clinical
workflow multiple people are sharing one
device it might be in a hallway in an
exam room on a medical cart that could
be in an all-in-one on a chrome box or a
Chromebook and the wonderful news here
is that we're able to complete clinical
workflow and the shared user workspace
through our partnerships with improve
ADA and healthcast so where that badge
tap and go is concerned we actually do
have a demo of it at the health care
industry breakout on that side of the
showcase floor so definitely encourage
you to check out what our shared
workstation use case looks like after
the session today
digitized training and communications
fun fact training is a common use case
where a lot of customers start their
journey with Chrome the reason for that
is because typically training
departments have a smaller pool of
devices that are in a siloed environment
and so that silo creates a more
palatable situation to run a POC and
pilot and a fun fact for you as well or
an anecdote I should say one of our
customers from Wisconsin actually worked
with us at hims 19 in Orlando in
February and shared that in their
training use case they were preparing
for incoming residents for the next
educational season and they by their own
measure saved 150 hours in time from not
having to image devices but rather and
roll them into the management console so
they felt like those were really great
results and as such they have now
started to look at Chrome for other use
cases
and finally temporary staff has anyone
here ever forgotten their laptop at work
couple people I actually did it two
weeks ago I was really embarrassed but
the great news is that Google has a
solution called grab and go
and our IT department created it a while
ago and the reason why they did it was
to help with end user productivity
uptime so in our grab-and-go solution
which we are demoing at the chrome
enterprise breakout in the workplace
transformation space what happens is
that an end user will go to a hardware
kiosk which is available through one of
our hardware part are our partners and
they check out the device login through
their cloud-based profile and they're up
and running for the day or the week if
they're visiting another location and
then once they're done they simply log
out and return the device to the
hardware kiosk now you might be thinking
well what does that actually mean
notice in this situational that I just
described there was no provisioning
required by IT for that end user to
start doing their job which meant that
they were able to start immediately and
there was no deep provisioning time
needed for the IT department which means
that the end user experienced more
uptime or access to their information
and the IT department won because they
did not have to serve that particular
incident so grab-and-go is a wonderful
solution and maybe you have healthcare
vendors that you serve or other people
that rotate in and out throughout your
facility so definitely check this out at
the workplace transformation boot moving
over to the patient facing use case we
have two examples to talk through today
the first being self-service in the
self-service use case this is where
we're talking about kiosks being used
for patient check-in
and check out to take surveys to verify
address information insurance when the
patient is able to do this on their own
that saves on administrative time from
back office staff so that freeing them
up to do other things and it also is
nice for the patient because they're in
more direct control of their own
information and then finally the in-room
entertainment and information use case
this might look like a a tablet at the
bedside it might look like a nope
Chromebook being used in a waiting area
or it might look like a chrome box
attached to a monitor in a hospital room
and in this particular use case a
patient facing app would be delivered to
the patient so that they have more
direct access to their own information
lab results the list of their clinic
visits different different things that
they would want to have access to about
their care plan or about their treatment
or having access to directly communicate
with their care provider so there are
multiple applications available for this
today but where it comes in intersection
with Chrome is that at the end of 2017
we started to deploy the Google
Playstore across all Chrome OS devices
and just like we talked about how you
know we leveraged these entertainment
apps for our own use on the way to San
Francisco this week patients are still
people at the end of the day and they
want to be able to be people and to
access different information so through
the Google Play Store on Chrome OS
you're able to deliver some of those
applications like Netflix like Spotify
for entertainment use and help through
some of those feelings of anxiety that
they might be feeling
so with that said you just heard a lot
from me about how Chrome enterprise
works I'm gonna turn it over to Jason to
Hany from hundred and help who is a
current chrome customer so he can tell
you about their chrome journey Jason
Thank You Angela I could ask you and
everyone so so I'm gonna apologize in
advance I am from New Jersey and you
know we don't have the hills that we
have here in San Francisco we have Muir
foothills compared to this and I also
took up running about two years ago I
thought I was all that kind of running
last night and my knees not quite what
it used to be so I go crashing down
please you know it's for no other health
reason other than I was stupid yesterday
so anyway I'm so I'm Jason tahini I'm
the director of IT 400 and health and a
little bit about 100 health care system
we are a community hospital with a very
far reach we have about 75 physician
practices we are you know founded in
1946 literally the miracle in the
cornfield
we raised a whole bunch of money a long
time ago and part of the hundred and
healthcare system and I'm going to talk
a little bit as Angela mentions about
some of the Google products that we use
and we found to really be powerful for
our organization so in health care we
really have some serious IT challenges
you know we have legacy applications so
unless you're one of the lucky few and
you can afford some of the really large
EMR systems you're left with about eight
or nine different EMRs in your health
system you know a lot of them are codes
base that was delivered developed back
in the 90s I know that's for us some we
have some of the smaller Mars are just
really that ancient and and not to
mention even if you have some of the
larger in Mars you still need like
surgical systems and you need things
like nutritional management systems I
mean really complex to run a hospital so
lots of legacy applications and then
because of the legacy applications
partially you have we have data silos so
we end up with information kind of all
over the place across different in
different EMRs you know we try to tie
that together with something called an
interface engine right but and and it
works but you know not really quite that
seamless integration of it we all would
like to see I mean some of the newer
standards with fire they were coming out
are gonna are going to kind of hopefully
help with some of those issues and then
we have rising costs so I think I read
as a 2012 is about three hundred seventy
seven billion dollars in impact the cost
of impatient
health care in the United States right
that just impatient that's a whole lot
of money right regulatory environments
so you know we have everyone everyone
here if you're in health care you know
what hip is the security and privacy
rules you know security rules how we
protect the privacy of our patients we
also have things like PCI if you take
financial transactions a whole lot of
PCI compliance that you need to do
basically if you're taking bit doing
business with credit cards need to be
compliant for PCI and we have limited
skills where to start
you know so I have you know lots of
talent great teams but not enough of
them right so we really looked to like
others looking to the cloud - you know
we're how can we leverage cloud and we
picked Google Cloud and I've been
pleasantly surprised very happy with the
product so far so a little bit about the
solution and healthcare in the cloud for
us Chrome Enterprise is at the center of
that and that's everything from the
Chrome browser on a desktop that we
standardized to things like Chromebooks
chromeboxes grow up the meeting room
boxes as well you know that we that we
use that we're starting to use we also
use Docs and sheets which are your Word
and Excel replacements and really Google
did a nice job with that they're kind of
one of the first ones that are that
real-time collaboration in Docs and
sheets and we took advantage of that
early and very powerful team drive
another great one for you know if you
want to replace your SharePoint
America's a SharePoint product we had
about 40 different SharePoint sites out
there and we move the team drive we were
able to consolidate that and we put team
drive together with sites then you get
to do a very nice internet application
or you have the same functionality as
SharePoint essentially so alerts Center
you can't talk you do any kind of
presentation especially in healthcare
about talking about cybersecurity so the
nice thing about alert center is it's
across all the entire Google platform
all the products you're using it's kind
of that that alerting to tell you hey
something's going wrong whether it's on
your mobile device some suspicious
activity on a mobile device to a
something going on in the Chrome browser
it's kind of all the things as a
consumer that you see out there you know
are you when you connect from a trusted
computer do you trust this computer or
not so that's that's what this is for
your enterprise
so the solutions expanded we have so I
talked to them about the share points
sites and you know silos team drive and
Google Sites really working out very
well for us they are we're able to
consolidate and get rid of our
SharePoint footprint legacy applications
you know we so we have to support these
applications and you know kind of how do
we do that with chrome and the nice
thing what I like about chrome is it's a
modern operating system really a
cloud-based operating system so but we
can still tie it to some of the
traditional ways of how we used to do
things would be the I our virtual
desktop infrastructure so you know plug
in your provider Google pretty much
supports it we were VMware horizon
customer and it works very well with
that although it works the citrix as
well and we found that has been very
nice so we've been able to kind of put
put chrome devices out there and so
provide access to our legacy
applications multiple collaboration
tools so things like what I didn't
mention on the slide before Google meat
and hang out so meat is your WebEx
replacement it can be used for training
video conferencing really nice and the
great thing about it is it comes with
when you get the suite Google's suite
which I also haven't mentioned Gmail
right so you know our journey started
with Gmail and G's sleep but it's all
part of the suite when you use that you
get Google meat and hangouts so very
nice very nice tools that we've been
able to take advantage of on the
regulatory side you know I mean doesn't
get any more important than the security
piece of this and what's nice is your
security hardened chrome OS so these are
we can put them out there without
needing expensive tools to manage them
right so they're encrypted by default
you can use the Google console to manage
all that and you know I mean I even for
things like software deployment you
don't have to go out and get a separate
tool of the software deployment your
chrome devices and we found there's a
reduction in cost there right because we
don't need those expensive tools anymore
so easy patching on the Chrome browser
Angela mentioned that's Auto patching it
really is true I was pleasantly
surprised by this you know another
another tool that we needed to kind of
patch our Windows environment not needed
in the chrome environment just it is
self patching and it really does work so
on the rising cost right we estimated
we're about four hundred six hundred
dollars per Chromebook deployed and
that's because you don't have kind of
the expensive cost of your Microsoft
licensing as well you know for office
and things like that
and it's you know one with email Gmail
get a nice a nice great cost savings for
us and they're easy to use products I
mean it really are you can
put him out there when we went live with
Gmail and G suite you know we did all
the training to our organization we did
all those kinds of things but to be
honest they had seen the product already
in their kind of consumer life right so
it really helped with that transition
and we found that it's been an
evolutionary process since then we just
kind of put it out there and folks to
start to use it right it's been it's
been a great thing so Google cloud
increased productivity it's easy to use
it is budget-friendly secure
out-of-the-box and does provide better
collaboration all the tools are very
tightly integrated and very powerful
when you use it as a platform so a
little bit of case study here this is in
New Jersey they back in 2017 the state
required us to do put out a New Jersey
early early intervention system for
child development so the goal this was
the catch developmental disabilities and
children early in the in the patient's
home and and they put this progress note
tracking system out there that we they
required our clinicians to use it we had
used it about 30 days so our director of
child development kind of came to it
came to me in a panic say hey we need
devices to get out there you know we
need to do this in 30 days how are we
gonna do it right so we're able do with
Chromebooks it was amazing how fast we
were able to deploy it since they're
secure out of the box it was a web-based
application it had everything that they
needed right and and we were able to get
it out there and then it was very
tightly integrated with our legacy
applications as well we provided access
to Windows applications through VDI and
and they had Jesus lead and Chromebook
great anything else that they needed to
use so kind of a nice story there and
you know still working out very well and
and always a good thing we're helping
out children something so talk we talked
about you know cybersecurity of privacy
and you know this slide really is about
the security piece of this you know I
mean I think back in 2016 Verizon put a
report out 90% of the breaches that
happen out there start with email so you
know the G suite we go Gmail itself very
powerful we do a lot of an email
security AI is incredible you get these
products kind of right out of the gate
so things like attach to the sandbox and
protection against zero-day threats and
and so that's basically a piece of
malware out there and nobody knows how
to fix and this is technology as put out
there for iGoogle to try to catch it
really without any kind of pattern or
any kind of traditional signature based
technology
we talked about protecting patient
health information encryption that rest
is huge you know for us we knew we
needed to do this we just could not do
it our data center I mean the cost for
us to take trip everything that we have
in our data center was really off the
charts not not really feasible so you
get this by the fall and I think I heard
that Google is one of the only ones that
in in their cloud environment they
provide the encryption by the fall so
that was very very very powerful
encrypting data at rest we were able to
do around regulatory you know the secure
a hardened chrome OS environment for our
works very well for our clinicians and
what's nice is the security that just
kind of works it doesn't get in the way
of the provider or the clinician
providing care which is always a good
thing in security the other big factor
for us on the business associates side
for hit but right it's you know if
you're gonna do business with a
healthcare is to you really have to sign
a business associate so Google does
signed HIPAA business associate
agreements so very you know and and that
was a key one for us early on when we're
looking at Jesus we probably about six
or seven years ago they weren't quite
there yet yet but now they are doing
that so so very powerful you know strong
regulatory compliance advanced threat
protection cloud-based security at is
always improving I mean you get these
things without thinking about it as the
features just kind of come out you do
have to turn them on but you truly have
seen at least on a Google side we've
seen the power of cloud on Google and
getting these you know getting features
turned on kind of right away especially
the security part of it
[Music]
you